en el estadio ya poma de duala se
consumó la catástrofe argelia el último
campeón de la copa africana de naciones
se despidió en la fase de grupos del
torneo al caer con claridad por 3 a 1
frente a costa de marfil fue una
despedida muy deslucida para los zorros
del desierto que se mostraron como un
equipo previsible sin demasiadas
variantes en la ofensiva y también
mostrando falencias defensivas que
fueron aprovechadas por un equipo
contundente como el de los elefantes de
costa de marfil que supieron sacar
ventajas rápido en el marcador con los
tantos de franquicia y de ibrahim
sangaré en la primera mitad en el inicio
del complemento el trámite fue similar
costa de márfil amplió la diferencia con
el tanto de nicola app en el inicio de
ese complemento argelia tuvo una opción
de descontar con un penal que riad mares
terminó estrechando en el palo y
simplemente sofía en vender acá a poco
del final apareció de cabeza para
maquillar un poco el resultado y para no
dejar a argelia sin goles en el torneo
se despide dejando una muy mala imagen y
necesitando reinventarse de cara a lo
que se viene principalmente la
clasificación al mundial de qatar
mientras que costa de marfil da un
fuerte mensaje al resto de los equipos
en el torneo y será rival de egipto en
los octavos de final por otro lado línea
ecuatorial la única selección africana
de habla hispana también se aseguró su
lugar en los octavos de final al vencer
1 a 0 a cierra leona con el tanto de
pablo gannett y de esta manera consuma
una gran primera fase en la que por
ejemplo venció a argelia venía de
conseguir ese resultado histórico
también este triunfo de costa de marfil
le permitió a la pequeña selección de
cómodas clasificarse resultados de final
y será rival del anfitrión camerún